Final Fantasy fans eager to learn more
about Final Fantasy 15 don't have much
longer to wait there's going to be new
news and footage coming soon I'm Kate
and this is your gamespot news update
square enix announced on tuesday that
the next active time report live stream
will take place this coming saturday
january thirtieth game director Hajime
Tabata and marketing director Akio of
Fuji will appear during the event during
which they will showcase the latest
battle footage and scenes of magic this
active Time Report will also provide
updates on another event in March we're
Square Enix is expected to finally
announce the long and development
role-playing games release date the game
is officially do out sometime in 2016
possibly this summer January's active
Time Report broadcast will be streamed
live through Square Enix's youtube page
starting at 8pm PST or 11pm EST as a
teaser for the show Square Enix also
released four new Final Fantasy 15
images showcasing main character Noctis
performing a fire spell and making use
of stealth among other things what are
you hoping to see in Final Fantasy 15 is
it too much of a change from the norm or
is it just right let me know in the
comments or come and find me on Twitter
I'm at how not to draw thanks for
watching and for all your gaming and
entertainment news keep it gamespot